Because dude,
I had a cracked filling and they took the filling out.
Oh,
and the fucking smell that came out of my mouth.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Because there was an infection and I had a wound up getting a root canal.
It like you could hear it like pop through and then just this fucking shit
breath.
My father is fine.
He was sleeping with his wife,
said you have to go to the dentist.
So why does your breath is so out of control?
So apparently he had an abscess,
a sack of bacteria in the back of his mouth.
Well,
when they took the feeling out and they popped by accident,
the sac,
the nurse through
fucking dentist walked into the room at that moment
and through the [inaudible] fest.
Ooh,
she just puked
like that.
Yeah.
I never had the balls to tell someone that breaths.
When you work with them,
you have,
if you work with them,
you have to tell friends where I would want them to tell me like,
your breath stinks.
I'm going to tell you the worst one cool thing about black people.
They'll tell you
no problem with that.